wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
ich habe nur ganz wenig zeit
sollte dir gerne ein paar sachen für den
umzug mitbringen ein paar kleinigkeiten
die kannst du sicher gut gebrauchen
tut mir leid ich muss gleich wieder los
ich hab doch diesen ausflug also tarek
und max haben den ausflug gebucht am
liebsten würde ich ihn absagen heute
kriege ich fünf die mails mit
freizeitangeboten tickets werbung ich
weiß doch gar nicht was ich damit machen
soll
wahrscheinlich ist das meiste werbung ja
es gibt sehr viele angebote
ich soll wandern gehen ich sollte segeln
oder surfen kannst du dir das vorstellen
surfen was denken die sich nur in meinem
alter also klein macht und macht gleich
weiter ich will euch nicht von der
arbeit abhalten
ich habe auch überhaupt keine zeit ich
muss noch einkaufen gehen und ich muss
tarek und max fragen ob sie schon ein
hotel für mich gefunden haben es ist
alles furchtbar stressig kann ich dir
helfen
nein ihr habt doch genug zu tun also ihr
lieben macht's gut und kann mich mal
besuchen nico dagegen nach region und
vielen dank für die sachen die hat echt
keine zeit keine zeit